[Music]
as you know I'm a massive fan of yours
you're a brilliant fellow and and I was
thinking today you often play I don't
know how else to say it
you play jerks a lot it needs to be
something that you you love to play well
I play I did I mean the only one that
did people here might know is I mean
Tropic Thunder I played a jerk who got
his head blown off
yes ten minutes into the film Ben
Stiller gives me the odd throws me the
hour bone of a part you know if I don't
get my head blown off then they make
sure I thought I'm miniature and Knight
the museum playing a small toy sold
right right but I yeah i i do play jerks
but that's fine but it seems like it's
you got to do what you what your best
art you know yeah it's just i'm getting
a bit bored of it I'd like to I like to
play a could you play like a superhero
I'm trying to be I think I think I could
but I'd have to be a superhero who's
also a jerk yeah that's fine has there
been that has there been a superhero
who's you know drinks a lot and is a
jerk to people there well yeah and you
know he's just yeah he's just he's an
alcoholic but occasionally he saves the
world can't remember that he's done it
yeah